a woman can't change a man because she
loves him a man changes himself because
he loves her
a very small degree of Hope is
sufficient to cause the birth of love
[Music]
is like any luxury
you have no right to it unless you can
afford it
the most precious possession that ever
comes to a man in this world is a
woman's heart
foreign
[Music]
is when you see someone's strengths love
is when you accept someone's flaws
when in a relationship a real man
doesn't make his woman jealous of others
he makes others jealous of his woman
[Music]
to love someone is nothing to be loved
by someone is something
to love someone who loves you is
everything
I love her and that's the beginning and
end of everything
greatest thing you'll ever learn
is just to love and be loved in return
a dream you dream alone is only a dream
a dream you dream together is reality
Love Is a Song That Never Ends
being in love with you makes every
morning worth getting up for
sometimes emoting how you feel makes you
who you are
if you can keep your woman happy you can
possibly do anything you want
if she's a keeper you don't need to look
around for another
chivalry is still alive if you don't let
it die
communication is the key to a successful
relationship
[Music]
we accept the love we think we deserve
we loved with a love that was more than
love
we don't love with our mind or our heart
we love with our soul
the pain of partying is nothing compared
to the joy of meeting again
foreign
the good life is one inspired by love
and guided by knowledge
one hour of write down love is worth an
age of dully living on
there may be a brighter star but through
my eyes the light of you is all I see
a man falls in love through his eyes a
woman through her ears
in hatred as in love we grow like the
thing we brewed upon what we loathe we
graft into our very soul
[Music]
togetherness passion laughter Faith
trust and jealousy are the essential
ingredients of love
true love will Triumph in the end which
may or may not be a lie but if it is a
lie it is the most beautiful lie there
is
you know you're in love when you can't
fall asleep because reality is far
better than your dreams
[Music]
When a Man Loves a Woman he can't keep
his mind on nothing else he'd trade the
world for the good thing he's found
love doesn't just sit there like a stone
it has to be made like bread remade all
the time made a new
a man who loves you the most is the man
who tells you the truth about yourself
[Music]
this is the miracle that happens every
time to those who really love the more
they give the more they get
I fell in love the way you fall asleep
slowly and then all at once
[Music]
scariest thing about distance is you
don't know if they'll miss you or forget
about you
[Music]
we come to love not by finding a perfect
person but by learning to see an
imperfect person perfectly
if I had a flower for every time I
thought of you I could walk through my
garden forever
[Music]
yes I am drunk and you're beautiful and
tomorrow morning I'll be sober but you
will still be beautiful
any man who can drive safely while
kissing a pretty girl is simply not
giving the kiss the attention it
deserves
foreign
[Music]
you cannot leave everything to fate
she's got a lot to do sometimes you must
give her a hand
it doesn't matter if the guy is perfect
or the girl is perfect as long as they
are perfect for each other
biggest coward is the man who awakens
the love of a woman without the
intention of loving her
[Music]
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength while loving someone deeply
gives you courage
foreign
you can only show her the multiple ways
you can love her by loving yourself an
equal amount
love is the only reality and it is not a
mere sentiment it is the ultimate truth
that lies at the heart of creation
[Music]
lust makes us forget anything we want to
the greatest relaxant the greatest
stimulant
[Music]
love is an untamed Force when we try to
control it it destroys us when we try to
imprison it it enslaves us when we try
to understand it it leaves us feeling
lost and confused
Love Is Lost in men's capricious minds
but in women's it fills all the room it
finds
someday you will meet her she will make
you feel Serene and calm she will
understand you
you won't have to explain to her things
about you and your life
a woman quickly surrenders to that man
whom she does not love and resists for a
long time the one whom she has fallen in
love with
because with her beloved she wants to
appear good
and with the unloved she's not ashamed
to appear bad
people are made of hate and of love
and more of hate than love but love like
the sun sets a fire and melts everything
[Music]
all love that has not friendship for its
base is like a mansion built upon the
sand love to endure life sorrows and
Earth woe needs friendship solid Mason
work below
you don't love someone because they're
perfect you love them in spite of the
fact that they're not
loving someone and having them love you
back is the most precious thing in the
world